many of the people not all many of the
people who were involved in the Nazi
atrocities were perfectly Ordinary
People they were just like you and you
think no I wouldn't do that it's like
that's not what the evidence suggests
there's a great book about that
terrifying book called Ordinary men and
it's about the initiation of a police
Battalion from Germany who had grown up
before the Nazi propaganda Mill got
going they're just ordinary middleclass
guys their Commander told them that they
could go home that they didn't have to
do this job and that there would be no
repercussions the vast majority went
along the guys that left thought I don't
care I'm not doing this but most people
didn't and part of the reason they
didn't do it is because they were loyal
to their to their peers by the end of
this these guys were taking naked
pregnant women out into the middle of
fields and shooting them in the back of
the head we do have a culture worth
defending and we have laws worth
defending and a founding worth defending
and all of those things if we will not
allow those things to happen What will
come on the other side are much worse
people who will do unspeakable things